welcome to another edition of famous
Friday and what I try to do is learn
from success of famous entrepreneurs
because any problem that you're facing
right now it's already been solved you
don't have to go out and find this
solution yourself somebody else has
already solved it and by studying famous
entrepreneurs and how they became
successful you too can become successful
really quickly so today's theme is
believe in your dreams and the stories
of Barry Gordy now Barry Gordy is the
founder of Motown Records and hugely
successful in the music industry made
him a millionaire many times over
inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame but how he started it's a story
that most people would have given up on
and it's a good lesson to learn that you
need to continue to believe in your
dreams
so when Barry was growing up he he had
two loves boxing and Jack's that's what
he loved most in the world and he
figured okay I got a pick one you know I
got a setting out in my life I got a
pick one I love and work on it so he
chose boxing he won fifteen straight
fights he was an up-and-coming boxer and
he was doing really well and then the
Korean War broke out he got drafted to
go fight and by the time I came back he
felt he was too old to continue his
boxing career and you know even at that
point a lot of people give up right you
know you were doing well at something
and it's taken away from you outside
your control and you know you say okay
well I took my shot it didn't work out
but Barry didn't give up you know he
decided okay I can't do boxing anymore
so I'm gonna do my second love which was
Jack and he opened up a jazz store in
Detroit and what he found out was that
the the Detroit audience you really like
jazz they want it rock and roll and so
his company had to close down he went
bankrupt
he had the closes business and so
another another shot to the gut right
another Wow you know both my dreams now
don't work out what I'm gonna do and he
you know was out of money so he went to
go work at Ford and he was nailing
upholstery inside their their Lincoln
automobiles and again a lot of people at
that point would quit you know they'd
say okay you know what I tried twice I
tried both my
it wasn't working out I have a nice safe
steady job that doesn't really make me
happy but you know I tried I tried to
better myself and it didn't work out so
what do I do now but not Barry you don't
get to continue going and what he did
was he turned to songwriting and he
started writing songs and he sold a few
of his songs and I got to the point
where after he sold two songs and you
know what I'm gonna try being a
songwriter and he quit his job at Ford
and started writing songs and then he
found out that the industry was a really
tough one and it was hard for him to get
paid and the turning point for him this
is what helped him really explode came
when he was he had sold a song to a New
York company and they refused to pay him
and he was gonna take them to court and
when he realized that the legal cost
would be more than the worldly payments
that he would get from them that he
dropped the case and he realized you
know what I can't just be a writer the
power I need to have power and the power
isn't being the production house and so
he launched his company and that led to
the creation of Motown Records and that
let him become you know
multi-millionaire and an icon in the
music industry but it all started
because he continued to believe with his
dream you know one dream was taken away
from her the next dream was taken away
from him but it continued he continued
to believe continue to fight for it and
he continued to think that you know what
I don't want this average ordinary life
that everybody else has I don't want to
be working on a Ford assembly line the
rest of my life even though he bet on
himself once it didn't work out he bet
on herself again and didn't work out
continue to better themselves and
eventually worked out so believe in your
dreams those you're watching if you
liked this video you can subscribe to
the channel you can support me by
clicking on the link in the description
and leave a comment let me know what you
think the comments leave me a lot to me
so thank you and I'll see you soon